alright well here on overtime and let's
get the questions from the people who
wrote in what does the panel make of
michelle duggar statement while
campaigning with rick santorum that
overpopulation is a lie I mean about
denying science right I mean you know
what it is I hear this all the time they
say I've ever flown over the country and
when you look down there's a lot of
space that's true but that's not the
issue it's about resources it's true we
could actually fit on the planet a lot
more people especially now the China and
India are eating meat and getting cars
we just can't do it we would need like
you know to triple the population we
need like five more earths again this
comes from scientists it's not in the
Bible it's probably [ __ ] what how
can you give 19 children the attention
that they need to grow up that reality
show bankrolling all those 19 kids even
healthy it's a healthy way to go I just
think she's exhausted from all the
beatings 19 kids that's a lot of history
we even have 19 kids she's pregnant like
every year well I see this is where 19
kids and there's no you can no one can
stop anybody from having that many kids
no of course not but it's just ridic
I don't know what made me think of this
but I did I was gonna defend Mitt Romney
for a second on the show
and we ran out of time but he got caught
this week what would the Liberals were
all about this gaffe that he made this
joke about how his father had
transferred jobs from Michigan to
Wisconsin and everybody said this showed
him to be a bit I don't understand why
that's such a horrible gaffe you know I
mean he didn't send the cut the jobs did
you - yeah you know he changed jobs and
that's what CEOs do they figure out a
way to make the most bang for their buck
this they went from Michigan but people
in Wisconsin benefited I assume the jobs
went there why is it that bad we're not
against liberals aren't against anybody
being fired ever are we well it's just I
guess the thing is it's at some point
isn't going to be in Michigan I mean
what's he gonna say it's like oh hi
honey like my dad kind of like screwed
you guys will vote for me anyway
it's just he doesn't seem to she's
probably a CEO this is the CEO most
people and when they do it in America as
opposed to India or China I think that's
something to be at least somewhat
thankful for okay I mean I just you know
like they said there's a liberal bubble
too you know they get mad at [ __ ] that I
don't understand okay black night asks
rich or at least since 93 percent of the
income growth has gone to the top one
percent during the recovery why is it
wrong to tax them well I think we should
ask you you're the one that gave the
million bucks but that's not a tax
I know it's I was tax deductible that
and it's not even tax deductible did you
know that it was just lying around
you had all this left yeah I was more
insulted about the people who said I
can't believe you had a million dollars
20 years
he pays well I couldn't say 1 million
dollars you owe people money and then
you went and gave away this yes I'm
driving a cab I don't have expensive
hobbies you know most people in
Hollywood they you know either collect
cars or paintings or they're uh tear
away and you know I don't have kids you
know I mean it
I applaud your support of the First
Amendment but what do you make it a
question no problem with more taxes if I
thought that government used them use
the tax money efficiently I know that's
a silly argument because they never will
government no I mean in the 50s and 60s
government actually did function more
efficiently before there was all the
regulation and bureaucracy we make
things bigger we throw money into things
and we hope for these great results you
think there was less regulation in the
50s when they were building the
interstates Golden Gate Bridge they got
that up in three years how long did it
take for them to do that roadwork in
Boston I mean it's still ongoing it's
like somebody we're doing rich people do
pay more taxes they pay at a higher rate
they pay more just based based on how
much they get comes in and about it
almost half almost half that that's true
almost half of the working population
pays no income tax they have to pay what
do they pay the question is what should
they pay and since they've gotten all
these great advantages from this country
including making a lot of money don't
they owe the country more
[Applause]
the majority of what goes into the
coffers is from a small percentage of
people and about half the people do not
pay federal income taxes they pay other
kinds of taxes they pay the payroll tax
and write the sales tax inequality is
such a blind spot on the both the right
and the left the left you know money can
fix everything let's put more money into
government and then on the right not not
understanding that yes inequality is at
its worst level since I want it early
1900s in America you know when rich
people used to take their money and
voluntarily build public works like
college yeah I don't do it now they put
it where it's Mitt Romney's money but
Mitt Romney has in all fairness donated
a lot of money to charity he's know that
[Applause]
in contrast Santorum hasn't donated
anything and he's the one throwing out
is you know why because he said he the
reason he didn't is because he has a
special needs child and he does not and
then the government doesn't pay for all
that it's the greatest advertisement yet
for universal health care you cannot
transfer money except with a leaky
bucket I mean government will all we
have to kind of accept that the
government will never be if it's totally
efficient that you can't there's no way
to do it and that's not a that's really
not a writ we've we've tried this
experiment for 30 years and was very
interested during during the New Deal
yeah and there was a lot of construction
there was the TVA there was the
interstate project and God knows I do a
very good point about the citizen we
have the we used an investor we used to
invest in young people we said we're
gonna educate a generation of Americans
so they can go out and out-compete the
world now we say and it's you it's your
career good luck we tripled the tuition
on these young people that's not just
bad for the kids that's bad for the
country how no country in the world is
refusing to invest in educating its kids
China is doing it Indians doing it
Brazil is doing they're making it easier
for the kids get educated we're safe
that's all the richest people ever born
don't have to pay a penny more attacking
we're banning a whole generation of
Americans a constant association that
education has to do with earning power
there is another purpose for education
which is to improve the quality of life
as you improve improve the experience of
life and the idea that you're gonna put
throw money for this thing so somebody
can make a living or a higher wage or
else as they're going to debt to be
educated to have an experience of life
that is not meaningless I did when I was
in college I had no idea of like taking
courses to get a job I was an English
major I wound up using English in my
career you're always fluid yeah we gotta
go thank you very much folks you're
terrific
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests to a questions right after
the show at hbo.com